hey guys what's up Samuel Leeds here and
on this video I'm interviewing Portland
waters and poor man last year did 30
warm property deals and they just their
last two days have been basically no
money down by refurbishing refinancing
we put it up pretty much all of their
money they're very good friends of mine
so please welcome to the show poor Dena
waters hello very nice
how's it going guys it's going great you
think it's great to have you in my home
it's not easy I'm also you spoke
yesterday at the property investor
circle yes we do and emotionally connect
before and how did you feel before
speaking oh my goodness when I went in
the door and it was just full of people
is about 54 people there no just sort of
a good I'm so nervous yeah your mouth
was dry mouth I think this is on that my
comfort zone yeah is the thing this is
the difference between you guys and most
people successful people feel the fear
and do it anyway yeah cuz you win the
spoke yeah and how did you feel
afterwards yeah really good yeah you
smashed it from that yeah when people
come up came up afterwards and said well
done and they really enjoyed it that was
brilliant
yeah yeah fantastic so why don't you
give us Paul perhaps give us a bit of
background how did we meet what were you
doing and what was life like when we
first met we met at our local pin
meeting we live from Eastbourne these
Sussex and you traveled all the way down
L believe on the day that you're
supposed to move house yeah
yeah and you Paulie you turned up all
the way down throat down to respawn
that's when we first met you that
evening from there we went on to get
your book from there we went to your
crash course crash course deal finding
and zero sign up sign that was a it was
a partnership and and as I say the rest
is history
really so that was what like just over a
year ago it was just a year ago in
February you're going to Christmas
that we very first mean yes and what
what what were you doing when we first
met you were working long hours as a
flora yes
self employees you have employed me and
your back problems on the way thinking
oh my goodness I'm going to do this
until I'm 70 and then retire on what
exactly and I mean what were you doing
at the time Ann and I assisting Paul
yeah yeah during the books
yeah I'm Tim yeah okay now you needed on
maybe 18 months you're in Provence and
you still are flooring but not going to
be doing that for much longer Arizona
looking to give that out body into the
air and you said it's weird because
you've been doing that for 40 years is
that speaking your bread and butters be
coming from that and there's almost like
it's hard to let go but I think I mean
it's crazy I've been saying to you for
the last six months let go quit all of
all of the other repetitive members what
James was on you about yesterday saying
because did you make more than us
different flooring awful property last
year probably from flooring okay but it
was cause this year it be property it's
probably going to be more from property
yeah yeah yeah well he's gonna be more
probably definitely yeah so why don't
you talk us through then I know you did
a lot of sourcing in the early days and
that was gone in your main strategy why
did you choose that strategy it to start
off with it wasn't going to be a
strategy funny enough it wasn't it and
we sort of just just fell into it we do
you showed yourself to do it and I
thought well we'll give it a go yeah and
we just but it's a very simplistic thing
really you if somebody it's successful
but something can they show you how to
do it it's very easy to copy them isn't
it if they're not successful you tell me
how to do it you're not gonna copy them
but if they're successful and they tell
you how to do just just do as you're
told really yes um and it just worked so
so straight away we started really
enjoying sourcing finding properties
finding deals and I still enjoy doing
our students you and also I mean it's
funny you said that about copying
because that's school they say you know
don't copy other people that's cheating
yeah but in life in life it's completely
different it's the opposite it it goes
back to my white when I was a child when
you go to school you can't add up can
you the teacher teaches you to add up
waking there that they teach you to try
it up so just copy them but do as I say
yeah and and just taking into adult life
if you have any successful in school
if someone's if you sit next to someone
who's successful and they're really a
smart kid and then you just look at the
answers and write them down in your
paper
that's gives you the bad yeah successful
people in the real world do exactly that
they find people to have the answers
they sit next to them and they just call
me what they're doing that's it which is
what you basically what you did yeah and
you are moving your first 12 months how
many deals did you do in the first 12
months it was more like 40 40 deals
that's incredible that's even just over
poor thing yeah man I mean I couldn't
even keep up because I see you all month
and you've a lot of the 19 deals now
I've like amazing and of course I can
see what dealers are doing because
you're you're you're you're selling your
deals through our company so I can see
what you're doing and then at next month
or so you'd say oh it's 26 now and now
it's 30 now so over 40 meals maybe a
little 343 deals in your first 12 months
and before that
did you add loads of property experience
not allowed to jam what had you done
before that we'd we've had a little bit
of Education and we had a couple of by
two Nets seem short single biting errors
so you've got like your typical amateur
investor yeah that's got one or two
accidental properties you've been on the
odd couple of course attention sorted
yeah yeah and then you went from that to
come in on the crash course yeah and you
didn't go on the crash course once
you've been on the ground three or four
times and yeah I think at least four you
know
yeah you know so you went from that to
going on the crash course and taking
some advanced training with myself just
suddenly doing 43 deals in the year most
of those being sourced yeah but still
you're getting you're betting a fee for
that said then do in I mean your last
two deals have been incredible why don't
you tell me about the last two deals
that you've done the last two properties
we walked both knees were both needed
refurbs yeah
so we got them below market below market
value the first one we reached the
actual purchase price of it with the
money we got from sourcing which
financed the refurb on it
the second one we've reached for the
purchase price of it and we've an engine
investor who's invested the money to do
the fixing up on that one so that's not
cost any money whatsoever
yeah the first one we all would you be
financed we're just waiting for the
money to come through would you do you
mind if I ask you some specific
questions about the finances so you can
really look at the case study and then
go Kate I guess yeah because I know some
of the YouTube listeners that they you
know they really like to get down to the
nitty gritty details that I right yes so
the first house then that you did have
out of the ones you've done recently out
of these these - Ygritte then Grigsby
right they are yeah and you guys love
Grimsby any go yeah yeah so the first
one how much did you buy the house for
fifty seven thousand fifty seven and you
and you borrowed the money from a
bridging company to do that yes so how
much did the bridging company lend you
to buy it
Anderson one hundred one hundred percent
so you bought it for 57 yeah and the
bridge company dead you are 100% of the
money because it was below market value
because it was below what was the value
of the house um it was roughly 25
percent below market value so you bought
it for 57 and it was worth what like 65
five years and some other okay so you
bought a 57 you borrowed all the money
from a bridging company yeah how much
did the bridging company charge you the
fees on that - you know we don't have to
pay any monthly payments on that it's
for everything
all right charge a small fee yeah yeah
okay so maybe 2% or something like that
so if they let you all the money then
you did a refurb yeah how long did the
refurb take ten weeks and how much did
it cost
15,000 15,000 and how did you pay for
that with the money I saw similar
sourcing money that you'd be making
resource and sales
all right so 15 grams you
you're only that you'd made from
sourcing bills fantastic 15 run into ten
weeks and then now you just refinance
there yes so if you bought it for 57 and
you spent 15 that means 16 72 was the
total it was I'm out that he put
anything there you didn't put it in you
got bridge Inc how much have you managed
to refine that set up to ninety nine
ninety thousand which is incredible that
really is incredible it is so and it's
been valued they've said yep you can do
a refinance at ninety you're waiting on
the money to go in yeah which will mean
that you'll be able to pull out how much
money we'll end up with six thousand
pounds left in the deal cool
so basically all said and done including
all the different figures you're left
with 6k of your own money in the deal
and you're gonna rent the house out for
about five fifth day it's already
rendered it's incredible fantastic
what a brilliant what a brilliant deal
did you have any hiccups or problems
with that along the way was it what
smooth silent getting near the end we
had to get a new boiler which we didn't
think he was gonna act again which is
part of the fifth day yeah we didn't
okay yeah boilers they look nice though
yeah yeah yeah it's just not worth him
in your face so it's worth having just a
little bit of buffer for things like yes
brilliant I mean how did you find the
deal it basically right mover right
brilliant because I always think that
you know when you start off getting into
property you know you just speak to
estate agents you've gone right move
then when you become a professional
investor you said oh no all ideals need
to be off market offline or foiling them
via Facebook ads and leaflet drops but
then actually when you become seasoned
what you guys on that yeah yeah back to
estate agents because the thing is
there's hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of properties on write news
now it might be the only one percent of
them are good but when you know how to
identify the good ones and because of
the right knowledge then suddenly right
movies like gold a gold field go boys
yeah yeah yeah
so you found out on Rightmove did you
just how do
if you spent a 15 grand on it or
whatever that it would suddenly be worth
90 grand how did you work that cab guys
now once again moving what's sold in the
area what's sold in that road saying
that a big room same size yes what they
said in poor and you got it add a bit of
a bargain yeah how did you manage to
negotiate 25 percent below market Bowyer
thank you because of the state of it I
think it really was in a bad state yeah
it was in the Polish state
okay well congratulations on that deal
and you were also just about to you know
you've just completely on a second deal
instead of the builders about another
two weeks work yeah I'll see you that
one's almost gonna finish there yeah and
then roughly what the figures on that
hand once you buy for 85,000 and what's
the value of it about 130 to 140 English
that will be my once it's done that
money yeah so you bought it for 85 the
reverb is costing again fifteen thousand
which is you total about in is 100 yeah
you borrowed all the money from bridging
gun from an angel investor next and then
you're going to refinance it for about
135 putting out how much of your money
all of it we yeah we should get a little
money out of it that's incredible but
absolutely fantastic but when people say
you know are you can't do no money down
deals it's not possible I mean you
started in this game with not a lot of
cash you don't have a been or anything
like that with what you've achieved you
know I mean and and now have these no
money down there what would you say to
those people that say it can't be done
well we thought exactly the same if it
couldn't be done
and it all sort of happened by accident
the angel investor even happen by
accident so yes it can definitely be
done it happen by accident because you
got yourself the right knowledge yeah
you mean you paid for education yes you
put yourself in the right place at the
right time yeah and then suddenly you
just happened to get look at yeah that's
right isn't it yes it is right because
you work for it yeah you know you've
attended that you've attended the
training you've gone to the networking
event you've done the dough and then
suddenly everyone's like they've done
well for themselves all they must be
just got lucky
Society goes back to the same saying
doesn't even harder you work the luckier
you get yeah exactly
and the more you
invest in yourself and the more you
educate yourself and the when you put
yourself in the right place at the right
time it's like oh you're so lucky to
happen to me that put that angel
investor know because I went networking
yeah so tell us about how did you manage
to raise the 15 grand from the angel
investor that was down to hell yeah
that's me it's just a just a normal
conversation footage from a family
member actually and he just happened to
ask me
however because he's really into poverty
how things were going and I said we was
just struggling a bit on the second
house trying you know to get the rest of
the money to do the refurb on on that
one and and I said in fact we've just
put an offer through to the Builder
saying we you know would you prepare to
accept another ten percent in cash if
you let us pay you at the end of the
refurb once you know you'll be fine it's
been - it's been refinancing quickly
says hang on a minute don't say how much
did you do you need I said fifteen
thousand they said so you can give them
fifteen hundred pound cash and I said
yes and they said well I'll do that
really release it literally within an
hour the money was you know absolutely
brilliant
for so many reasons and it's this but
this is what we teach right this is the
stuff we talked about
yeah didn't know what you did which is
so genius which is the way we teach you
the programs that you know it's instead
of saying oh please do I have some money
you know I'm desperate because when
you've got desperate on your forehead
attractive you say oh it's going really
well a bit short on the money so we've
offered the builders this
well we've offered this other investor
this and then they go oh what I could do
that yeah so you've almost created
you're not asking them in a direct way
but you're letting them know that you
need it yeah and you're you've got
another third party and then suddenly
boom that's when it happens or no thing
you do which is brilliant was a lot of
people that they don't think to ask
family members or close friends the
people right in front of their nose that
can really help them maybe whether it's
with raising finance or a joint venture
we might be yeah that they they don't
they don't think to ask them so they're
going up networking and they're going
out but they're forgetting to us so that
was that's fantastic
you can't in the save the day
wonderfully because the builders I don't
know what they've said that there's a
chance they would have said no yeah one
of them said yes straight away the other
one was thinking about it and then when
they knew we haven't got the money right
up you know it right up front at the
beginning they said alright we'll start
the second house in two weeks time then
but no I really want them to start
Monday so soon as we had it I'll text
the build and I said you can start
Monday we've got the money in our
account now yeah nice they started yeah
they would Danny because they've already
talked about well maybe next time then
another angel investor that definition
of the names of investor is what
basically somebody that comes along
financee for you had a percentage really
yeah yeah basically they lend you money
for a fixed term for a fixed return on
investment they were an angel investor
and then in joint venture partner is
someone who's got a stake in the deal
yeah yeah fantastic so um what have been
the biggest lessons then over the last
12 months do all the properties that you
saw the properties that you've bought
yourself what would be their real kind
of learning points and lessons that
you've learned that you'd like to pass
on
I said let's definitely take action when
you go to you know the course is your
courses it's no good when you co go back
home just to go back into your normal
everyday life yeah you've really got to
like I think you know a lot about what
you've learnt over the last couple of
days and just take action really just
don't you know do something about it
it's not all going to come to you you
have to go out there and work for it and
find good places to invest and you know
and just put a lot of work into it
yeah you know that's it basically
educate yourself yeah because you buy
the wrong property that's right you can
end up with a lot of money tied up in
that property for a very long time it
can be an expense yeah yeah mistake to
buy I mean those two lessons that you've
just said between the two of you paul
saying educated
and you saying take action yeah I didn't
that is the duck if you do those two
that's that's the best advice yeah all I
can pluck it up I could give as well so
um absolutely fantastic so where are you
gonna go from here then what's next
because at the moment we're in the
middle of buying out there Townsend
goodness me
yeah which is also in fact this is a
property we were viewing to do you know
to source it on but when we saw it
there's a lovely young couple and the
house was dreadful you know really
dreadful the state of repair wasn't it
new and the tenants do were quite
shocked because I didn't even know it's
going on the market because they said
that there's a new landlord a year ago
and he'd promising all these things and
he said they didn't do anything so he
said that they paid themselves to have
central heating put in downstairs and
that when they could afford odd bits of
money they bought wallpaper and did or
bits of decorating themselves and did it
up and they were quite shocked that oh
my goodness we've just played our center
eating put in half the house and now
we're going to get kicked out the sort
of thing yeah and I just thought I can't
let that happen they're really nice they
deserve a break and I said we're gonna
try and ride this house and we want you
to stay and that's basically where it is
that house it was 48,000 and it came
that the beach company said they
couldn't if they'd find it hard getting
some mortgage below 50 and they said
would we are pair price to 50 and I was
adamant saying no because I never met
the landlord but I thought it was a bit
of a rogue landlord because the tenants
would pay 500 pounds a month and say the
house was dreadful so I said no and I
said what we would do is once we
exchange contracts if the landlords then
paid to get the hallway down with the
damp proof course take the polystyrene
tiles off the two bedrooms that it you
know that that would come up to 2,000
pounds worth then we would if he does
that once we've exchanged then we would
pay 50,000 and he's agreed to that
fantastic see a lot of people have just
said yeah go on more pi 59 if we can't
get a mortgage but you were really
creative amazing thing about the owner
pay which is really great fantastic look
that and it's not it sounds to me poor
like you've got a very very a wife who
really makes things happen yes
would you be able to be doing this
without huh no how would you be able to
do it about Paul what's it like what's
it like working together as a
partnership in a marriage building your
dreams building your financial future in
property it's been brilliant a little
bit yeah yeah it really is we we just I
think we work so well as a team
yeah I like complement each other yeah
and even with the by two let's like you
know doing them up and choosing what
sort of kitchens and what sort of
feature walls to have and the color of
the carpets to match and I don't know we
just really come together and both
really really enjoy it and not for you
and we get to go away like if we this
year we've gone away with every two
weeks for two days at a time to have you
know that patch in Grimsby you're
looking at houses so it's nice to go up
there together and you've also been
going away to other places yeah I see
pages across Europe yeah yeah with you
went to Cornwall with you yeah what's it
like been working with me over this yeah
yeah lovely pleasure to know you some
real really that's the motivation that
keeps you going because it is very easy
yeah to fall back into you around the
crash courses yeah yeah yeah motivation
yeah good likewise it's been amazing
working with you guys you know you're
such a beautiful couple and it's been
such an opposite to joy and Paul you
need to just leave your flooring
business alone I mean you are you know I
know I know technically you are still
working Paul but what's it like now like
how is life different now knowing that
really you're not going to need to work
from now on compared to oh my gosh how
long am I gonna have to be doing this
for um I was a lot easier because none
of us getting any younger
it's a physical job and I physically
can't continue to do it
I'll do a lot less now than when I think
back to when I was a lot younger the
amount of work I used to do back then to
what I can do now it's I just can't
carry on doing it down so it's wait it's
happened at the right time it's been a
necessity than this view it has yeah
yeah but I shouldn't have got me ages
ago yeah what would you say to someone
that was thinking about investing in
maybe further training with myself or
going to the crash course for the first
time what advice would you give to them
it's well it's an investment in yourself
isn't it and it's an investment for life
it's not you're not you are buying
something but you're not buying
something that you can dispose of it
you're investing in yourself and you
live the knowledge for life yeah it's as
simple as that really yeah and whatever
you change for me you're not fine I
don't know what if you're not buying so
you are investing and the money will get
back to you you'll get your money back
on the first deal really yeah yeah if
it's the five you're buying it's not a
cost it's an investment yes an
investment yeah I mean our investment
was paid back very quickly fantastic
well thanks some of you go on the show
have you got any final words you want to
say before we wrap up now I think we're
just going to carry on doing what we do
in finding below-market brand new deals
doing them up and getting a money out so
I know below market value properties for
sale yeah fantastic well guys I hope you
found that useful if you'd like to get
in touch with with paula man I will put
there may be facebook details or
something you have at the bottom on the
video and have a wonderful week and
we'll see you next time
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time